When it comes to the Netflix original series
Stranger Things, there are a seemingly endless
supply of Easter Eggs and knowing nods to
other movies and pop culture properties.
In fact, it might be faster to list all the
bits of the show that don't actually refer
to something else, rather than those that
do.
And that's not all.
Sometimes what looks like an Easter Egg — like
Lucas's collection of He-Man action figures
and Maxine's nickname of Mad Max — are actually
just details that come from a show set in
the 1980s.
But in the interests of making your next rewatch
more satisfying, here's a not-anywhere-close-to-complete
list of some of the more overt Easter Eggs
you might've missed in Stranger Things Season
2.
And before you get mad and open up your face
with rage like the demogorgon, just remember:
spoilers ahead.
Sean Astin never says die
Sean Astin, who plays Joyce's doomed boyfriend
Bob Newby, got his start as an '80s movie
icon, playing Mikey in 1985's The Goonies.
That movie, which featured a group of plucky
kids getting in way over their heads on a
huge adventure, is one of the most obvious
sources of inspiration for Stranger Things.
But it's actually one particular line of dialogue
in episode 5, "Dig Dug," that makes Astin's
casting truly work on a list of Easter Eggs.
While helping Joyce, Will, and Mike try to
find Hopper in the maze of tunnels underneath
Hawkins, Indiana, he jokingly asks about where
the map leads.
"That's the objective, find the X."
"Yeah?
What's at the X?
Pirate treasure?
Heh heh."
"Bob!"
And Goonies, as you may recall, revolves around
Mikey and his friends' quest to follow a treasure
map to find the lost loot of the pirate One-Eyed
Willy.
"It's Willie!"
"One-Eyed Willie!"
Mad about Paul Reiser
While he's probably best remembered these
days for his role as Paul Buchman on the 1990s
sitcom Mad About You, actor Paul Reiser appeared
in Stranger Things as Doctor Owens.
He's the new guy running the lab in Hawkins,
who's trying to figure out just what the heck
is wrong with Will Byers.
But back in 1986, Reiser provided one of moviedom's
most memorable bad guy turns in James Cameron's
action-sci-fi sequel Aliens.
He played Burke, a two-faced corporate goon
who sends Ripley and the space marines to
find more xenomorphs, despite knowing that
they'd all probably die horribly in the process.
Owens has similarly dubious motivations here,
since neither Joyce nor the viewers can tell
if the good doctor is really very good at
all — at least not at first.
We find out by the end of the season that
Owens is more Buchman than Burke, though it
costs us a Bob along the way.
Not much luck if your name begins and ends
with a B in Hawkins, huh?
Staying frosty
Want more proof that Reiser's appearance in
Hawkins is a direct nod to Aliens?
Among the many popular franchises Stranger
Things refers to throughout its second season,
Aliens might be one of the most prominent.
In episode 6, "The Spy," Doctor Owens oversees
a group of gun-toting soldiers who make their
way through the tunnels under Hawkins to try
and confront the shadow monster the kids later
refer to as the mind flayer.
He watches on monitors as the soldiers are
ambushed by the demo-dogs who've flooded the
tunnels.
That moment takes its cue from a similar scene
in Aliens, when Burke and Ripley watch the
space marines investigate the alien-infested
colony.
Later in the movie, Corporal Hicks talks to
Hudson and Vasquez about the need to be on
high alert:
"We're all in strung out shape.
But stay frosty."
So it wasn't too surprising to hear one of
Owens' soldiers say this towards the end of
the episode:
"Alright, stay frosty, boys."
Do Raimi
One of the other major influences that you
can find all over season two of Stranger Things
is the movie Evil Dead, the 1981 horror classic
by Sam Raimi.
For starters, when Eleven is home alone in
Hopper's cabin in episode four, "Will the
Wise," she discovers a secret door in the
floorboards that leads to a hidden basement
that contains secret knowledge about Hopper
and her own past.
The shots that lead her there are pretty visually
similar to the scene where Ash and his friends
discover the Necronomicon in the basement
in a woodland cabin of their own.
Then there's the abundance of "shaky P.O.V.
cam" shots, which is when a camera zooms along
the ground quickly to show the ominous movements
of an evil force.
Raimi used that technique to show the point
of view of the evil spirits stalking Ash and
his doomed friends in all three Evil Dead
movies.
Meanwhile, the Duffers bring shaky P.O.V.
cam to Stranger Things when Will sees the
now-memories of the mind flayer, who's tunneling
under Hawkins and spreading his own brand
of evil.
Add the abundance of creepy vines wrapping
themselves around human bodies to hold them
against their will, and the similarities are
impossible to ignore.
Still somehow not convinced the Duffers are
paying direct tribute to Raimi with season
two?
Take a look at this Stranger Things promotional
poster — and then look at this original
Evil Dead movie poster.
Raimi should maybe get a co-directing credit
for Stranger Things season 2.
The Regan era
Finally, as if throwing Aliens and Evil Dead
into a blender with Goonies weren't enough,
the Duffers and the rest of Stranger Things'
producers threw in a healthy dose of The Exorcist
from 1973 for good measure.
We've got it all.
There are young innocents being subjected
to a bunch of pseudo-scientific tests to figure
out what's wrong with them.
Angry mothers demanding that a bunch of quacks
be less terrible at their jobs.
And there are possessed kids being strapped
to a bed for their own good while the demons
are being forced out.
The only thing that's missing is projectile
vomit:
Oh, wait.
That's in Stranger Things too.
Never mind.
Hail to the King
Matt and Ross Duffer, the twin brother creators
of Stranger Things, make no secret of their
appreciation for the works of Stephen King.
So there are plenty of subtle and not-so-subtle
nods to the guy whose work inspired so much
of the show.
For instance, Bob tries to tempt Joyce with
the prospect of relocating her family from
Hawkins, Indiana.
Where does he suggest?
Maine, which just so happens to be the creepy
northeastern state that features prominently
in so much of King's work.
Then there's the character of Eleven, whose
psychic powers look pretty reminiscent to
those we see in the 1984 King adaptation Firestarter.
A little girl violently busting stuff up using
only her mind?
Yup.
Finally, there's the secret knock that Hopper
uses to let Eleven know that he's home.
"(knocking)"
A post on Den of Geek points out that if you
convert the knocks to Morse code, it translates
to the word "ITS."
That sure seems pretty similar to the title
of Stephen King's legendary novel It, which
features a group of outcast friends banding
together to defeat a monster that's terrorizing
their town.
The fact that actor Finn Wolfhard, who plays
Mike on Stranger Things, appears as Richie
Tozier in the 2017 big screen adaptation of
It, potentially making Hopper's knock one
of the best-hidden Easter Eggs in the whole
series.
He's back!
In Easter Egg form
Near the end of Episode 4, "Will the Wise,"
Dustin comes home to spend time with his rapidly
growing pet demon, Dart.
That's when he's shocked to discover that
Dart has broken out of his cage and found
a new favorite cuisine: Dustin's cat, Mews.
What could this be a reference to?
You guessed it:
"Hey Willie!"
"Alf!"
"Willie!"
That's right, ALF — that wacky puppet from
the planet Melmac who had his own sitcom in
the late 1980s — also liked to feast on
felines.
"Any last meows?
Nope?
Then I'll see you in a few days."
Is it possible that this Easter Egg is actually
just more of a coincidence than an intentional
one?
Yeah, probably.
But is it way more fun to imagine that the
Duffers and the rest of their team spent hours
trying to think of a way to cram an obscure
reference to ALF into their hit TV show and
that only super ALF nerds would recognize?
Absolutely.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this other cool stuff we
know you'll love too.